hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay
you just lit on thing on fire that was
blocking this door
very convincing by the way and I got a
sewer key anything else in here look
like it okay this is for that locked
door that was over to the left there or
twitchy guys are gonna jump out at me
he just looks really dark deep in we go
also okay why even bother with that
small hallway I don't know I need health
but not I'm not enough that I need to
use another syringe I could probably
make it I just be careful I'll use my
gun up need to reload my gun never mind
come on now get yeah there we go
click click ok alright
Oh ah what the hell ah hey what the [ __ ]
are you doing ya know get on with the mo
he just saw the guy's head off I woulda
show ha ha ha oh oh [ __ ] he was talking
oh man oh alright our own are you so
slow uh was that an attack my dad begged
Oh Oh George what up what up gosh we can
reach
there's a weak spot what what what huh
what no I got that ha ha what the hell
was that what is that doing I don't know
he's doing I don't know I don't know I
don't know nope ha ha you so big it back
slow stupid and ugly ok ok
car Jang there we go oh that was
something I'm so good nope not even
close buddy
oh you're close buddy get over here I
need to go that one coming Goomer Goomer
I got something to show you Oh what that
you scared I would be too just long I'm
trying
hi ah
this is a decision too bad for you Oh
what oh oh yeah whoo almost didn't make
that one but I'm so pro call that a
mouse yeah he'll you cut free like I
just gave up my knife oh wait was there
didn't you saw this guy's head off dang
it I just got rid of my maybe it's
something else maybe maybe I'm not just
but I probably will that's that's how I
roll I fail hardcore all the time
okay anything in here Locker syringe
um I guess okay
what's through here ha look clunk ah
there we go saw okay that's better
all right there we go there we okay
we're good we're good
I quit the saw maybe nope it wouldn't be
good anyway come on come on what the
hell oh you gotta be kidding my save
game is before the boss mother of [ __ ]
oh that is just [ __ ] you trapped me
god damn it alright I'm gonna cut it
here I'll be back after the boss so you
don't have to go through it again okay
be right back
hello everybody I'm back okay just got
past the boss easiest hi probably could
have kept a recording but now we got my
gun not quite ready get my gun ready I'm
going to show these ladies a good time
you're dead where's the other one since
when does it take six bullets to kill
you or before I run alright getting out
of here going back saw him up good sugar
sugar sugar pick this one you don't even
know why you need the key why murder a
perfectly nice gentleman and then saw
his stomach open why poor guy yes use
key lock the door so he was the key
this is the key to the wrong door
okay I'm gonna assume it's go use the
wrong door
let's come back here find out that
that's to keep that door I'm gonna be
mad all right whatever okay is it this
door
let me save I wish it was an autosave
but autosave function this game but I
guess that would defeat process or the
body okay there we take it off there's a
safe one right here
well I'm stupid hoes out there ah what
was that something went red I didn't
quite see what it was okay no no oh oh
give up here I'm ready for you Oh blood
everywhere
I bled everywhere Oh
Varda I can still say I will die what
why I don't wanna die ah what do you
think I think many things I think
possums are a weird animal do you like
this not particularly you don't know
anything I know many things [ __ ] her if
you just could understand understand the
mathematical quantity
on these of this generation I never
wanted this okay
oh he's going on whoa
my brain is living out here oh wow
I just want you to die just die I don't
want to die
no no die no dying hands why man
laughing stop touching my feet ah I'm
not gonna make it I'm not gonna make it
I'm gonna go god damn it what what the
heck aw but we go oh that was scary
I'll go what uh-huh Oh lady I'll get out
your own your blood walls
I've gone slowly now oh so scary
ah bring it on ah guess you I think
you're a [ __ ]
oh yes I do I know that you're gonna die
I can understand just fine I want this
brain own hands
come on God cut through the door inject
myself with morphine before I get to you
here we go up what's this blue super
juice up in my arm oh you're gonna die a
prize you get ready for some baton
action yeah your hands and nope no hands
ha ha no hands oh yes not that way
Oh get out of here I'm all out of energy
Oh which way which way ah yeah your
hands no hands in so many hands
seriously what the hell yeah oh yeah
here is you don't go into that with full
health you just die oh that's the car
crash in the beginning I think you did
fall asleep
I'm gonna go coma or when it was less a
that insane asylum damn it what was that
hallucinations probably am i calling
insane yeah yeah you are Shh it's not so
bad need to get some help or at least
just find my way back home yeah good
luck with that that's probably not in
the cards that doctor must have done
something to me that makes sense you
were unconscious for a while and he was
just standing under there okay I got a
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching hope you're enjoying it so far
and I will see you in the next part
bye-bye